president Trump's daughter and
son-in-law face criticism over their use
of private emails and text messages for
government business in a letter to the
White House House Oversight Committee
Chairman Elijah come and said the
communications of Ivanka Trump and Jared
Kushner raise security and
record-keeping concerns
he threatened to use quote alternative
means if the White House does not
provide more information Paula Reid is
at the White House with more on this
story Paula good morning good morning
president Trump spent much of the 2016
campaign criticizing Hillary Clinton for
her use of personal email
he even accused her of mishandling
classified information now those same
allegations are being made against his
own family an attorney for the
president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
admits Kushner used the encrypted
messaging program whatsapp in his
official duties including communications
with people outside the US the attorney
also confirms Ivanka Trump received
official email on her personal account
until September 2017 now senior White
House officials are prohibited from
using personal accounts for work unless
they copy an official account or forward
the message now Kushner's lawyer insists
that screenshots of his messages were
forwarded for archiving but he cannot
say whether Kushner ever sent classified
information via the app mishandling
classified information can result in
criminal charges the White House Counsel
tells CBS News it will review
congressman Cummings requests for
additional information now in a separate
request the White House is rejecting
demands from Democratic investigators
for details of the president's
conversations with Vladimir Putin the
White House insists the president's
conversations with foreign leaders are
confidential Gail thank you Paul